[Music]
it's interesting question what is
coolness it's sort of impossible to
define but sociologists have tried and
their definition I think is really
useful their definition is that coolness
is a measured positive rebellion against
an illegitimate mainstream and like
thinking of that all in one big pile is
a little bit complicated but when you
disentangle that it makes a lot of sense
it is a measured small rebellion a
little difference or distinction for a
mainstream that is considered
illegitimate or bad coolness is a
response to a mainstream it is in many
ways very similar to the sociological
definition of a cult a cult is also a
measured rebellion to a mainstream that
is considered illegitimate maybe the
best way to think about this definition
is to think about it through the lens of
dress codes for high schools right lots
of high schoolers when they attend a
school that has a dress code they try to
break from that code but only in ways
that are measured and positive right so
the dress code says you have to wear a
coat with a tie and a button-up shirt
maybe they'll undo the tie a bit or wear
a hat or undo their button-up shirt
they'll have measured measured
rebellions to that illegitimate
mainstream but it's not cool to go to
school naked it's not cool to go to
school dressed in some like you know
like some sort of weird superhero for
Tuesday
that's not a measured rebellion that is
outright rebellion and that is not
considered cool so you need a measured
rebellion number one but number two the
mainstream has to be considered
illegitimate in the first place in order
for the action to be considered cool so
in one study these researchers did
something really clever they told a
bunch of students who are who were you
know departing from the mainstream dress
code and in various ways they told them
the dress code was initiated to honor a
high school graduate who had died
overseas in a war now suddenly that
dress code wasn't illegitimate it was a
completely legitimate way for people to
honor a fallen soldier and fewer
students considered departing that dress
code to be cool
so it's very important to think when
defining coolness that you need two
parts first in your the mainstream that
is considered bad people need to agree
that the mainstream is bad and two you
need the rebellion to be positive and
measured it can't be crazy it can't be
insane and when you have those two
things together you have cool the
difference between that which we
consider cool and that which we consider
cultish because they're relatively
similar things they're both departing
from a mainstream is essentially degree
that cults are all designed around this
idea that most human beings or most
people in society don't get you or they
don't get this important thing they're
not religious enough they're not
thoughtful enough they're not
environmental enough that has to be sort
of the first principle of that cult but
we reserved the word cult for
essentially groups that are too far away
from the mainstream to be considered a
measured rebellion from it and so I
think that's exactly the right way to
think about coolness versus cultish Ness
is that we're all part of cults we're
all part of some we all disagree with
some aspect of mainstream social or
political thought but the but whether or
not other people consider us cool or
cultish essentially depends on whether
they think that we are departing from
that mainstream in a way that is
measured and positive
[Music]
you